- So a couple
things I wanna talk about.
First and foremost,
I wanna talk about hustle.
And, no better example of
hustle, than what just happened.
Right, we had a situation.
It didn't totally work out.
We improvised,
and changed the game,
and were still able to
deliver to the community.
This is something I do
all the time with Wine Library
as a retail company.
When a lady ordered a case
of Beringer White Zinfandel
in December, two
years ago in Westchester,
and FedEx fucked it up, and she
called the store complaining
that we were
gonna ruin her Christmas
'cause she didn't have
her Beringer White Zinfandel,
during a hail storm
while everyone was in chaos
trying to figure out what to do,
I just grabbed a case
and drove to her house.
That's caring
about your community.
This tonight instead
of saying, ah fuck it
nobody paid for tickets tonight,
it's not like
anybody really lost anything.
Mashable and I were upset,
we wanted to come through.
We didn't want people
to schlep over here today
and just for a meetup, that's
not what was presented to you.
So, we went fucking outside and
now we're gonna
crush a keynote for you.
(audience laughs)
(cheers and applause)
Let me tell you
one of the things
that's going through my mind.
A lot of people are
talking about the economy,
how it blows, how it sucks,
how people are scared,
people aren't spending
cash, all that bullshit.
Fundamentally to me,
what's gonna happen over
the next 24 months, is going
to be the biggest opportunity
in our space, created.
I'm gonna tell you why.
Social media or whatever
the fuck you wanna call it,
is mature, it's
still a baby but it's
more mature than people realize.
It's definitely a baby,
but it's mature,
like a baby with
a mustache, right?
(laughter)
So, what you have
to understand is this,
major companies,
a lot of companies,
are not going to spend money
on social media right now.
They're scared, they're cutting,
and the first thing they're
gonna cut, is things
they don't understand.
And so they're gonna cut some
social media opportunities,
which is gonna hurt
some of your businesses.
Because your business
is built on advertising.
I understand, however,
what you need to understand,
is the fact that
these major corporations,
that they're not jumping
into this space headfirst,
is the single
biggest opportunity for you.
Whether you're a
content provider,
whether you're
looking to monetize,
whether you're a middle
man trying to broker deals.
The longer the people
that already have established
relationships in the market,
stay away from this zone,
from this kind of product,
the more opportunity you
have in gaining brand equity.
Had The Wine Spectator,
or Robert Parker,
or The Wall Street Journal,
jumped into online video,
when I did, there's a
very good chance that I
wouldnt've not had
the ability to gain all
the momentum I did with all
the wine people in this space.
But because they
kept to the sidelines,
that allowed me to grow bigger,
stronger, and more powerful.
It's kind of like Yelp.
How many people here, in this
crowd, know what Yelp is?
Raise your hand.
(cheers and whistles)
Yelp, in a 36 month
period, has substantially
deathed and
hurt the Zagat brand.
How many people
here know what Zagat is?
Raise your hand.
Zagat now is playing catch up.
A 25 year old business, $50,
$60 million dollar business,
playing catch up.
What you have to understand
is that the internet,
fundamentally, has
changed the barrier of entry
to compete with companies.
The cost now to
build a business,
is your time,
not your pocketbook.
Because the gatekeepers,
the newspaper, the radio,
the producers, because they're
not in control anymore.
Because a clown like me can
put a camera in his office
in New Jersey, start drinking
wine, and build brand equity,
and nobody can stop me,
nobody, that's a major,
major shift, in what's going on.
Advertisers, that are
not coming to your space yet,
and are not
getting it, will come.
Because advertisers are very
simple, brands are very simple.
They go where
eyeballs go, right?
And eyeballs my
friends, are shifting.
As a matter of fact, I was
in a taxicab just now and
I called the phone number,
I wanna buy Wine Library TV
episodes in the taxicabs because
that's a captive audience.
You've got to start
thinking differently,
people are not watching
television the way they used to.
And on top of that, the way
content is gonna be distributed
through television
has already changed.
If you don't see
what's going on with Apple TV,
and what's gonna happen
with this Tivo, Netflix deal,
and what's going with Fios,
Time Warner, Comcast.
In 24 months, you're gonna
go to channel 999 on Comcast,
and search any content
you want on the internet,
and watch it on your television.
And that's when shit changes.
That's when content will change
and you'll be able to monetize.
The problem is everybody
that's standing here right now,
and all the people
I speak to all the time,
and talk to on a
everyday basis, have the same
fundamental fuckin' flaw,
They're not patient.
Everybody here
wants shit to happen now.
Shit's not gonna happen now.
So what you need to do is
take advantage, and hustle,
and build equity,
and build opportunity.
How many people
here own their name.com?
Raise your hand.
- [Man] What do you
mean by own your name?
- Garyvaynerchuk.com,
raise your hand
if you own that
for yourname.com.
- [Man] Should I go
out and do it?
- If you don't, that
is a massive mistake.
Go and find it.
- [Man 2] If you're
Jim Smith your fucked right?
- If you're Jim Smith
you're fucked.
Gary Vaynerchuk
finally paid off.
(laughter)
To me I'm fuckin' pumped.
I'm pumped because so much
good shit's about to happen.
And everybody in
our space is crying
that Main Street doesn't get us.
You're spending all
your time trying to convince
your friends to
sign up on Twitter,
and tell them why it's
important, why it works.
That is the biggest waste
of fucking time, on Earth.
Who gives a shit if they
don't know about Twitter?
Or if a company doesn't?
That should be your
mother fuckin' secret.
That's your secret,
keep killing that.
I didn't go
around telling people,
oh this is what im doing.
When I launched
WineLibrary.com in 1997,
every wine store in
America was making fun of me,
because they thought the only
things I was selling online,
were Opus One and
Silver Oak and all
these hard to get items.
'Cause why would Sally on 53rd
ever go to WineLibrary.com
and pick up Santa Margherita,
when she could
pick it up next door?
But what I realized then
'cause I got in the orders,
was people like convenience,
word of mouth,
everything's different,
culture is different,
people are different.
And so that's the same thing.
Everybody's gonna use
Twitter, whether Twitter is
Facebook, or whether
Twitter is Friendster and
there's gonna be
another product that comes out,
tweaks it, does
it slightly better,
the general concept of tweeting
out, and all that shit,
or texting on a big
level, is here to stay.
It's going nowhere.
Just look at the early
adapters, how addicted to it,
and how often they use it.
Alright, a couple other things.
Stop crying.
There's so many people
crying about something.
Making fun of somebody else,
thinking things suck,
worried about this.
There is so much
fundamental opportunity.
If you're trying to
make a business model,
let me tell you
what you need to do.
Whatever your niche is,
whatever your subject matter is,
go out and take your money.
And here's what I mean by that.
If you've gotta niche website,
you've got to go to Google.
How many people here
have heard of Google?
(laughter)
You've gotta go to Google,
and you've gotta type in
the name or the
keywords in your space.
For me that would be wine,
and then it would be cabernet,
Château Margaux,
things like that.
Any company that
has a box on the right side,
spends money.
Click that fucking ad,
find the phone number,
and call them and
convince those people why
your traffic, that is
so focused and on point,
to that subject matter,
is more valuable to them
than buying a fucking
stupid yellow pages ad.
It's there, you've
just got to take it.
There is so much
opportunity, the time is now.
Anybody who looks at a 17...
How many people here
have a brother or sister,
or somebody
they're very close to,
that is of the age of 14 to 18?
Raise your hand.
Watch those fuckers.
They're the ones that are gonna
tell you what's gonna happen.
It is clear as day, that they
are not going to be
watching television.
And I promise you one thing,
advertisers are not gonna
be spending
$80,000 for a full page ad
in Sports fucking Illustrated.
There's no value in that.
And they're realizing that,
and they're gonna shift,
and they're gonna put
their money elsewhere.
And no matter what you do,
you need to position yourself
to be in that.
Whether you're a content
provider, or a middle man,
or doing the
buying for a product,
and starting talking about it.
A lot of you work for companies,
when I consult for companies,
I get a lot of the same shit.
Yeah but I have a
muzzle, I'm not allowed
to tweet for my product,
there's too much red tape.
Whatever you do,
for your own brand,
because if you
don't say anything,
then nobody knows
you're thinking it,
communicate your
thoughts on our space.
Because when the
people above you get fired,
because they suck,
and they didn't use this,
and they're gonna lose, make
sure the new people coming in
have some content
that you saw it,
you just
couldn't make it happen.
It's a huge thing for people
to do on a corporate level.
But I really didn't
wanna talk that much,
I wanna do a lot of Q&amp;A.
I'll stand here until
there's no more questions left.
Please ask me any question,
if it's about social media,
wine, the New York Jets,
whatever you want, fire away.
- [Woman] T-shirts?
- T-shirts is
good too, fire away.
- [Woman] What's your
favorite five dollar wine?
- My favorite five dollar wine
is a wine called
Borgato from Portugal.
Borgato al Fonte.
Five bones fucking
crushes most $25 wines.
- [Oz] Hey Gary, so, a lot
of people are talking --
- What's your name, sir?
- [Oz] My name's Oz!
A lot of people
are talking about
branded social
applications being
the next big
thing in advertising.
What do you think?
- I think people have to
understand what advertisers
want. They want eyeballs.
So, I think anything that
has eyeballs is monetizable.
In my opinion, if you have...
2,500 unique people a day
coming to whatever you're doing,
you should be making bank.
You should be able
to live off of that.
I really
fundamentally believe that.
- [Oz] Really?
- Yes.
I know it sounds very low.
2,500 uniques a day, to
me, is very much monetizable.
The problem is a
lot of people (laughter)
A lot of people don't position
themselves to monetize.
And that's what
I get passionate about.
Wow, that's what I
talk to people about.
If you don't position yourself,
if you don't
redesign your website,
and most of all, if
you don't go after people,
I mean for me, I did
a case study for myself
when I had about four
thousand uniques for my show,
and met with a very
famous wine glass company,
and showed them all the
numbers and duh-duh-duh,
talked to them
about what they did
in the Wine Spectator
for $70,000 a month
and all this other bullshit.
And at the end of the meeting,
and I didn't
wanna take it because...
I didn't take
it because I've got
other monetizing
things going on,
and there was a lot
of different discussions
with television
going on at the time.
But, at that point, he
offered me $2,700 an episode.
That's, you know,
I do five episodes a day.
I mean that's real money.
Now, that's because it's niche.
Now again, you might
talk about technology,
a lot of you do,
that's not as niche,
and that gets harder,
that 2,500 might be tougher.
So, it is individual.
But, how many people
here consider themselves,
when they blog, they
talk about social media,
technology, that kind of
whole span, raise your hands.
- [Man] I do a lot.
- Real high, I wanna
see everybody who it is.
Every person that has
their hand in the air,
if you're not leaving a--
(laughter)
If you're not leaving
a seismic video reply
to every TechCrunch
post every single day,
you are a clown.
It is a massive-- IAM
Center Networks, thank you.
Sorry my friend.
But honestly, you know that--
TopMashable, sorry.
But, listen, I'm
telling you what I saw,
because that's where it was
launched first, what I saw.
These are places
where you can build equity.
The problem is people
stay within their own cocoon.
You need to go out
and work the community.
When Wine Library TV
had no viewers,
the way I got
them was by leaving
content on other wine blogs.
Even ones that were
ranked 11 million on Alexa.
You know what I mean?
Yes. You go to
them all because you
don't know where your
opportunity's gonna be.
People look at numbers too much.
Everybody gets
caught up way too much
in how many
people are in their RSS,
or how many
uniques they had in a day.
You've got to build.
- [Woman 2] If you had the ear
of all the top management
at these brands,
national brands.
- [Gary] Like Pepsi.
- Like Bonin Bough
at Pepsi, I was one of
the 25 that got that thing.
Okay, so, what
would you say to them?
What do you think
is the most important
thing they need to hear?
- [Gary] They don't--
The question is,
If I had the ear, and when
I do talk to some of them,
these big brands, what would
I tell them about the space?
Is that right?
The social media space.
So, here's their problem,
here's the problem
for Green Mountain coffee,
and for Pepsi,
and for Budweiser,
and the vodka brand
I talked to yesterday,
they don't think
there's enough people.
And they're right.
The most followed
person on Twitter is Obama,
and he has what,
100,000 people following him?
- [Man 4] Obama!
- Okay.
(laughter)
So, right? They don't
think there's enough people.
What I convinced
them is two things:
one, they suck. They
wanna spend money, right?
This space
doesn't cost them money.
It costs them time.
Which does have a money value.
But not like the
bullshit money they spend
by like, who are
those assholes that put that
thing on that
phone booth right there?
You know how much that cost?
A lot more than if you really
cared about your community.
So what I tell them is this,
you need to immerse
yourself in this space.
Because a lot of
the people in 2009
that do move the market are
paying attention to this market.
And it's a trickle-down
and the cost is so minimal
that there's no
value in not doing it.
You know what I mean?
So, that's what I tell them.
(audience applauds)
- [Woman 3] Gary-
- Yeah.
- [Woman 3] What do you
say to the people that say
that Twitter actually
degrades the English language,
- [Man] I've never heard that.
- [Woman 3] Is that a way
to us not communicating
in marketing any longer?
- [Man] I've never heard that.
- Right, so I don't give a shit
about the English language.
(laughing)
So that's first and foremost.
I think there's
absolutely no validity to that.
I mean, not marketing
in an effective way
with the English
language is the stupidest thing
I've ever heard
because most people know that
it's visual, it's emotional,
you know,
it doesn't need to be
spelled right to be right.
- [Woman 3] Thank you, Gary.
- You're welcome.
- [Man 5] If your
marketing is coming across
in 140 characters,
then you're doing
something really amazing.
That's basically
the bottom line on Twitter.
- [Gary] Guys, the problem is,
is everybody thinks about
marketing from like, "What
can I do to catch a splash?"
It's a game of nutrition,
it's a long process.
You really have to give
a fuck about your users.
The people that win really care.
They have a true community and
when that original fan base,
like for example my
Vayniacs originally,
they're the ones who
build your brand equity.
Whatever you do,
you have to make sure
your user is the
happiest son of a bitch
on Earth,
because then you crush.
Then they do it for you, you
will never have the time.
Everybody's always
amazed by how much
I do, but I'm only one person.
It's not scalable, I try
to make unscalable things.
I made a Facebook app the day
apps came out called Ask Gary.
You asked me a wine
question, I fuckin' answer it.
That worked for
about two days until
I got 900 questions an hour.
I mean, it's not
scalable, but if you
build passionate users
and you really give a shit
about them, then
that's the marketing.
The marketing is, see,
what you have to understand
is nothing's changed
except word of mouth.
Word of mouth is what's changed.
The biggest fuckin'
yenta on the Upper East Side
10 years ago, could've told
60 people about your product.
Now some clown in
Ohio with a Twitter account
can tell 4,000
people in one shot.
Word of mouth has changed.
And if you're shit is on point
and people are passionate
about your product,
that's what's gonna explode.
They can keep it going forever.
It's that tale.
Yes.
- [Man 5] Do you
run a business model that
not relying on content,
but the model is a
platform in and of itself.
- A business model
not relying on content,
but is a business model-
- [Man 5] It's a
platform in and of itself.
- Give me the example.
- [Man 5] I'm in the
process of building a platform,
it's called Democratus.
- Democratus.
- [Man 5] It's a customer
service platform for the
government helping people to get
satisfaction from the government.
- So, Get Satisfaction
from the government.
With-
- [Man 5] with ID, innovation
and actual experience.
- It's the same game.
When you launch that product,
it's an app, it's a web app.
So the early users,
you need to listen to them.
So when they're like,
"I don't like the submit button
"'cause it's pink."
You listen to that
shit or whatever it is.
And then, the other game
is to outreach, you know,
I'd live on Huffington
Post and shit like that.
Just building up
your street cred,
not spamming and
and linking your shit,
just getting you name out there.
When I left all those
comments on those wine blogs,
all it said was
Gary Vaynerchuk, that's it.
My name linked back to
my video blog, but I never
left a link in a comment.
Now a lot of people in the
SEO game think it's important,
I don't, I think it hurts you.
I think it shows
what your intentions are.
Instead of
adding to the community,
you're trying to suck out.
What I would do,
you, or somebody else,
be a face of this product.
Live and breathe every
politic blog on the internet
and build up that name equity
and they see your quality
responses and thoughts
and then they click
your name, find your site
and then when you
get them into your house.
You treat them like guests.
- [Mna 6] Well,
what you're saying is...
- [Gary] You've gotta
raise your hand sir.
- I'm sorry.
That's okay,
here is ladies first.
- Anna Savino @LucidAnna,
Gary, your tipping point
what, how can you
define it, what was it?
- [Gary] The question was,
"What was my tipping point?"
I've no idea and I honestly-
- When did you realize, "Oh,
it's working, I'm so psyched!
- [Gary] The day
before I started it.
(laughing)
I'm telling you the truth.
To me, if you're
passionate about what you do
and you love it more than life
and you believe you
know what you're doing
you've won already.
The day I felt I had something,
the first comment
I got on my blog.
The first day.
It was always going
to work, in my opinion,
there was never a doubt,
I believed in it that hard core.
I knew how had I
was gonna work for it.
That's it.
I don't believe in tipping
points at all, I really don't.
I'm sure
there's always a moment.
Was it when I
was on Conan O'Brien
or on the Wall Street Journal?
I'm sure there's something.
You know being on Diggnation,
there's definitely things
that made it go up.
When Center Networks linked
me up, National talked about me
whatever it may be
but I'm not sure.
But I know this,
I never looked for it
and way too many people
look for their tipping point
and that goes back to not
paying attention to your stats.
- I just wanted to say
@marshallsponder that it looks
to me like you spent a lot of
sweat equity and time
to build this up.
- [Gary] Always
- I mean that's the commodity,
yeah, not the commodity
but this is the pain.
- [Gary] If you don't work,
you have no chance.
Too many people, I mean this
takes every minute you've got.
Depending if this
is what you want to do,
it starts with
what do you want to do.
If it's just dollars
and cents, fuck that.
You're not gonna win.
You're not.
If you don't have pure
passion, then you've got no
chance of victory.
And so, it has to come down
to what you want, always.
- Yes?
- Jason Baer,
social media consultant.
Quick question
I bet a lot of brands
we've talked about say,
you know,
there's not enough
mass in social media,
just to put dollars against it.
And my response to that,
to my clients
is yeah, but
it's 1000% targeted.
There's literally no
waste in social media
because if you
put yourself out there
everybody that
interacts with you is
by definition
a fan of the brand
or they wouldn't be there
so there's no wasted impressions
the way it is with TV,
or radio,
or print,
or yellow pages
or direct mail
or anything else.
How do you feel about that?
- [Gary] I feel that the
difference between
a social media user
today--it'll change--but today
as a consumer of a product
compared to a
non-social media consumer
is that a social media
consumer is an advocate.
They continue the
building process of the brand
because they are using the tools
like Facebook Share,
like Twitter
like that,
to continue the
story about the brand.
- [Jay] Quick follow up
on that, Gary.
So what you're saying though is
so that you
advocate social media
as more of a customer loyalty
and retention tactic
moreso than a
customer acquisition?
- [Gary] Yeah. Both.
It's like players, right?
Everybody has players.
Your basketball
team you have 12 players
but 12 of them might suck.
You might have customers
but they might not be
doing anything for your brand
except a one way transaction.
I feel that social media
consumers are multiple traction
and can create so much.
Listen, if I love your product
and I tweet about it
and do a video blog about it,
things are going to happen.
And there's a lot of
people replicating like that
on many different levels.
You know what?
Let me finish with this
before it rains too hard,
but we can keep going.
I don't give a fuck about
one brand that doesn't get it.
Not for one fucking second.
You know why?
Cause they're going to
fucking lose and be gone.
I'm not in the business to
protect Pepsi from dying off
and letting some other
brand come in and take it.
because if you
don't think shit changes
when platforms change
just pay attention
to the five
biggest selling beers
when radio was in existence
and what happened
in the first five years
of television hitting
some sort of critical mass.
Because Schaffer
and Pabst Blue Ribbon,
I promise you,
they would re-do some shit.
(laughing)
So the landscape's
going to change.
The next Red Bull and Vitamin
Water and blah blah blah
is gonna come from this space
and they're gonna spend
a hell of a lot less money
than Red Bull and
Vitamin Water did.
Somebody's gonna crush it,
build a fucking
$100 million brand,
and do it for
less than $500,000.
And that's when
people are going to be like,
"Oh, now I get it".
(laughing)
- [Man 6] Do
you think the space
is going to become saturated
with people who don't
want to spend any money
and expect great results?
- Yes!
And then the cream
will rise to the top
and they'll get money.
It's going on right now.
There's a
fuckload of shit going on
but there's only a very
small tier that makes money.
Guess what?
That's how it is out here too!
- [Man 6] It's
always been that way.
- It's always that.
But everybody thinks
that if they have a blog
or if they're on social media
they're gonna get in
and they're gonna crush it.
You've gotta be good
and you've gotta
work your ass off.
It's the same principles
that have always existed.
If you suck
at sports radio talk
nobody is going to
listen to your shit
and you're not going
to be able to monetize.
So make sure what you do
is something
you're passionate about
and you're good at.
- [Man 7] Do
you swear this much
when you talk to
Pepsi and those big brands?
- Never. Only when I get people.
- [Man 7] Do you
tell them that they suck?
- Yes. Immediately.
Immediately.
- [Man 7] Do they give you
a hard time with that though?
- I have nothing to
lose. That's not what I do.
I do a lot of consulting
but it's not my
main source of income.
So for me to walk in--
I saw Tim Zagat at the Founders
Meeting the other night,
and said, "You're
getting your face beat in".
That's my opening line to him.
- [Man 7] He
smiled at you, right?
(laughing)
- And he said to his
friend, Bernie, from ABC
who introduced me.
He's like, "I like this kid."
Because I don't give a fuck
if he's out of
business tomorrow.
I really don't.
It's not what I can do.
I don't have the time
to help him. You know?
- [Man 8] What kind of
wine goes good with fish?
(laughing)
- White.
Guys, thank you so
much for coming out.
(applause)
Thank you for
braving the elements.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you guys.
- [Man 9] Thank you, Gary!
(applause)